all committee Reds red one
keep your eyes open boys over guys see
what I'm saying
where the hell is everyone hold position
Culver
you
I know you're upset but we talked about
this right look it's a little like
football I'm the team captain and now
it's time for us to go playing the big
game
but you've never been to war before just
kids for me
[Music]
two vehicles down other people need
immediate evac
copy I read one pound away gentlemen
this is a skilled and highly prepared
enemy who is coordinated a citywide
attack since I'm not gonna be here for
Christmas this year I thought maybe we
could celebrate early no platoons been
attacked I am anxious
we are all so anxious I don't see any
hostiles maybe it's over now now they're
just regrouping I promised I'd get them
back safe promise Tommy I'm gonna need
all of this to come back
everybody rebound
thank you Lord for all my wonderful
blessings bust them for their sacrifice
[Applause]
[Music]
I just gotta go I gotta go help some
people why those guys in my platoon and
my family too
[Music]
[Music]